et pour ne pas l'entendre et en
consommant puissant la ville on est
battu c'est le pakistanais qui
présentent tous
tout est ok tu fous hanouna crois que
les vacances c'est toute la ligne quoi
alors il va falloir se bouger gros
vivement la nouvelle saison pour tmp
vivement que ça reprenne qui j'en peux
plus voilà je te le dis je suis au bout
du rouleau il faut faut combattre
enfin baba il est rentré de vacances bah
ça y était de retour ça fait plaisir
alors on est juste vous faire un petit
message pour vous souhaiter une bonne
entrée jean macé moi j'aimerais qu'on
avait dit que leur souhaiter mordre et
oui et c'était donc à saly rentrée je te
souhaite une bonne rentrée et je veux
aussi des raumettes la coupe du champ de
plus moche de l'été or si nous c'est
fini
comment ça s'est passé l'été en tout cas
je vous souhaite une bonne rentrée à
tous les thés santé pmp c'est trop long
vu l'entrée avec deux parents fassent
l'arche moi ça me fait trop plaisir et
alors merguez pour tout savoir bientôt
tout le monde s'est réuni et bnp issa
jachère bon vous avez quand même
vachement manqué mois l'inspecteur
barnaby j'en peux plus il était grand
temps que tu reviennes en syrie je veux
de la petite beauté
je veux du coup nadal je veux du
chroniqueur je veux de la danse je veux
de la sardine
je te fais des gros bisous et il ya
quelqu'un qui voulait dire quelque chose
bonne saison à bout touche pas à mon
poste je voulais de souhaiter à toi et
ton équipe de lyotard hélas une
merveilleuse rentrer dans tpm p le seul
point positif de la rentrée c'est le
retour de touche par me postes de moins
sans touche pas à mon poste on joue
assez long des vacances sans touche pas
à mon poste c'est pas des vacances c'est
comme une caravane sans au vent à sa fin
sans boule jeune campeuse sont patrick
on est là on attend plus j'arrive mon
jeune sri lankais je te laisserai pas
reprendre que je perds mon poste sans
moi 4 3 2 touche pas à mon poste